- How would you guys like
to have a bath with me?
- That's very intimate
on our first interview.
(instrumental music)
And we are here in the heart
of beautiful Istanbul, Turkey
to experience a traditional
Turkish bath, or a hamam.
And while sometimes it's nice
to do things on your own,
it's even better when you
get to share the experience.
So I've decided to find
myself a strange man here
to have a bath with.
Since hamams are typically
separated by gender,
I am left with only being able
to ask men to join me at my bath.
We will find a man for me to bathe with.
We still have time.
Where are you from?
Well, I had a question
mainly for your father.
I'm experiencing my first
Turkish bath very shortly.
It's a cultural experience.
I was wondering if you would
like to take a bath with me?
(laughing)
- [Aria] Come on.
- There's no happy ending at this hamam.
- Where are we going?
- [Aria] It's literally around
the corner down the street.
- Okay.
- If you can do it too,
we'll get you in there too.
- All right, cool.
- With Shahz and Abdi
both agreeing to join me
on this adventure, we make our way
to the incredible
300-year-old Cagaloglu Hamam.
This is the type of thing that
hopefully decades from now
or possibly in a month or so
at one of your funerals,
we could talk about this.
- Well, I hope not in the
words, that, but yeah.
- You never know.
Death comes when you least expect it.
Let's get on in here before they back out.
Let's go. (laughing)
(instrumental music)
We are one of the oldest hamam.
- In the old times, people
don't have any much places
and go somewhere and spend their time.
A lot of people come
here, places like that,
and they spent their time inside.
And then they left as
a kind of a new person.
It's one of the biggest
part of our culture,
and we are trying to protect it.
- [Aria] Thank you so much.
And after we get appropriately dressed,
we're ready to start our treatment.
Oh!
- [Mustafa] Your treatment is
going to be in three parts,
first, the hot room rest.
- [Mustafa] It's like a sauna.
You're gonna get sweats
like 15 or 10 minutes,
it depends on your skin,
to get your body ready to treatments.
- [Mustafa] After that, our
therapist will wash your body.
- Oh, it's hot!
- [Mustafa] To clean you from your sweats.
And then he is gonna make a scrub
like 10 minutes on your body.
It's like a peeling for your skin.
Oh, hot!
- [Mustafa] And then
he will wash you again,
and while you're laying
down on the hot marble,
he will cover your body with the bubble.
[Mustafa] To get your
skin more soft again.
- [Mustafa] And then he is
gonna make a massage on you.
- Oh, oh, oh, (bleeping).
- [Mustafa] We call it foam massage,
or you can call it bubble massage.
It's the same name.
- Ooh, ow!
- [Mustafa] And then
he will wash you again.
And then your treatment
is going to be over.
It's traditional, classical
Turkish hamam material.
Although now veering
slightly off tradition,
I've been invited to take
what I've learned from Erol.
Oh!
- [Aria] And apply it to my new friends.
- No, no, no, no.
- [Aria] One of my favorite
things about traveling
is the people you can meet along the way.
And while I'm sure I would
have still had an amazing time
on my own, I'm glad I got
to share this experience
with a couple of guys who had
just as great a time as I did.
And as Shahz put it best
earlier in the evening.
- To travel and to friendship.
- Cheers.
(instrumental music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel,
and now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.